good morning my name is Hank green and
tomorrow is Super Bowl Sunday if you
happen to be watching this on the
Saturday before Super Bowl Sunday which
hopefully you are I know very little
about football in fact I had to borrow
this outfit jersey uniform what I don't
know what they call it I don't even know
what they call it in football from a
friend of mine so that I could appear
more Super Bowl ish we must accept our
true selves and my true self is a nerd
but I do like a good game of football
and hopefully that is what we will see
tomorrow in the meantime I thought that
I would nerd it up a bit and keep your
brain sharp with some football related
facts I'm going to tell you two
purported football related facts that
only one of them is gotta be true all
you have to do is click on the true one
or you fail it is time for your first
set of facts five-foot-six Darren
Sproles is the smallest player in the
NFL today or William the refrigerator
Perry was the largest NFL player of all
time
[Music]
you